Bobby someone's told me you were up for
the Costanza role in Seinfeld is that
true uh yes I was
how'd you blow that well I went in to
read for it and I was sitting on the
couch and I had the script and some guy
came over there's a lot of people in the
room there you know how to audition so
this guy's sitting next to me and he
says hey what do you think of the script
and I said well Jerry's a really funny
guy but whoever wrote this they don't
know dick about uh writing you know
sitcoms yeah and uh it was Larry David I
was gonna say that must have been Larry
David nice and so I didn't know and he
didn't say guess who I am and because
he's not like that and uh yeah he has a
pretty good sense of humor except for
that day and anyway so uh then it comes
time for me to go in and read and I walk
in and who's sitting there him him and
Seinfeld and George Shapiro and I said I
really don't have to bother auditioning
do I and they said nope
no but I've been up for Curb Your
Enthusiasm three times all right what
are you gonna do all right so that's a
really heartbreaking story it is